il n'est pas adopté mes chers collègues
nous
arrivons à l'article 3 t attendu et je
vais donner la parole au président
buffet rappel au règlement monsieur le
Président canner après le
Président Monsieur le Président bien
merci Madame la président quelques
observation au moment où nous abordons
le fameux article 3
chacun a bien compris
que il y avait des divergences de vue
sur cet article en particulier sur sa
portée on peut l'appeler des accords
c'est pas une question de pour être
clair là-dessus en particulier sur sa
portée l'article 3 d'origine du texte
nous n'y ét pas favorable en tous les
cas pour ce qui concerne le groupe les
républicains considérant que il pouvait
engendrer une régularisation
importante pour ne pas dire massive et
que nous n'étions pas sur cette ligne là
pour faire très clair nos collègues
d'autres collègues étaient plutôt nos
collègues centristes d'ailleurs étaient
plutôt sur une une une autre approche ce
qui fait que nous avions décidé en
commission des lois de venir en séance
pour mener le débat les choses ont
évolué chacun le sait maintenant puisque
nous les rapporteurs déposeront ont
déposé un amendement additionnel après
l'article 4 cet amendement additionnel
après l'article 4 renvoie au pouvoir
réglementaire je reste dans les grandes
lignes la possibilité de régulariser des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
présent sur le territoire avec ayant un
contrat de travail et souhaitant rentrer
dans la procédure d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour il y a
évidemment un certain nombre de
conditions supplémentaires dans cet
amendement je le présente mais les
rapporteurs le diront des conditions de
présence sur le territoire des
conditions de durée des conditions liées
au respect des valeurs de la République
au sens large du terme et la possibilité
et la demande qui est faite au préfet
dans le cadre de la procédure
d'admission exceptionnelle au séjour de
saisir l'employeur qui est le cignataire
évidemment du contrat de travail afin
que soit vérifié la réalité de ce
travail la conséquence de cet amendement
qui est déposé c'est évidemment la
suppression de l'article 3 d'origine
dans le texte la procédure va donc nous
amener à à cela je veux dire que c'est
un ensemble qui est bien clair nous
avons souhaité cette suppression et nous
voterons la suppression de l'artle le 3
qui été présenté par le gouvernement et
qui est en discussion maintenant et nous
proposerons un amendement qui est
l'amendement additionnel après l'article
4 qui remet en place met en place plutôt
le dispositif que je viens d'évoquer
j'indique également à la haute assemblé
même si nous ne sommes pas encore à
l'article 4 queégalement l'article 4
sera également supprimé les choses sont
parfaitement très clair voilà comment
les choses se présentent maintenant je
regarde le temps qu'il me reste
évidemment le débat va peut-être vous
apparaître un peu compliqué parce que
nous avons des amendements des
amendements additionnels pardon des
articles additionnels qui seront en
discussion mais qui seront supprimés
bien sûr mais la discussion aura lieu
c'est la règle il n'empêche que sur le
fond c'est
l'amendement 657 qui viendra remplacer
purement et simplement la suppression de
l'article
3 merci Monsieur bien qu'il soit voté
mais nous doutons pas président avant de
donner la parole au ministre je vais
donner la parole au président canner
pour un rappel au règlement oui madame
la Présidente Monsieur ministre madame
la
ministre nous souhaitons faire un rappel
au Règlement sur la base de l'article 33
alinéa
2 qui vous autorise madame la Présidente
à suspendre la séance à la demande donc
d'un membre du de la Haute Assemblée
c'est ce que nous vous demandons pour
une raison simple et j'espère que
Monsieur Darmanin ne voudra pas me taxer
cette fois-ci d'indélicatesse sur le
fait que je souhaite que sur ces débats
qui nous attendent nous souhaitons nous
puissions avoir le ministre auan ah bah
oui et je n'oublie pas qu'il y a
quelques mois je recevais dans mon
bureau et j'ai les témoins monsieur du
sopt et Monsieur daranin pour nous
présenter le grand équilibre je pas dire
le grand écart le grand équilibre de
cette de ce projet de loi entre la
partie intégratrice et la partie gestion
des flux migratoire donc je vous me
direz nous avons la chance d'avoir le
ministre de l'Intérieur donc
éventuellement il pourrait lancer un
avis de
recherche pour ministre disparus euh ce
serait intéressant mais là Monsieur dus
sopt n'est pas devant une autre instance
juridictionnelle si vous voyez à quoi je
peux faire allusion monsieur Darmanin
donc il peut venir au banc et donc
madame la Présidente je solcite un euh
une suspension de séance d'un temps
nécessaire un quart d'heure ou 20
minutes pour que le ministre Olivier dus
sopt puisse venir au banc défendre
l'article 3 et l'article 4 dont il est
l'initiateur au nom du gouvernement très
bien monsieur le Président canner cette
décision relevant effectivement de la
présidence je ne donnerai pas suite comp
tenu des nombreuses prises de parole
qu'il y a avant le commencement de
l'examen dans le fond de cet article
monsieur le
ministre
merci m la Présidente je regrette que je
ne vous suffise pas
monsieur monsieur le monsieur monsieur
monsieur le Président d'autant plus que
très largement et médiatiquement vous
avez pris l'occasion de dire la loi
d'armanin ou Géral d'armanin donc dans
se le coup vous cherchez vous-même
l'équilibre mais c'est évidemment une
démarche qui ne trompe personne pour
éviter de de parler sans doute de de ce
sujet moi je remercie la présentation du
président de de la commission des lois
et l'acceptation par la séance d'une
discussion commune finalement entre le 3
et puis le 4 b si j'ai bien compris qui
est l'amendement que a fait naître
madame la
rapporteur tout à l'heure et qui
discutera sur le remplacement du 3 en 4
b enfin qu'importe le
numéro quelle a été la volonté du
gouvernement et finalement quel est ce
qu'on nous propose la volonté du
gouvernement a été de régler un double
problème qu'aujourd'hui le règlement ne
peut pas
régler vous ne pouvez pas régularis
une personne qui est dans l'irrégularité
et qui travaille et qui parfois
travaille dans des conditions
extrêmement diverses on l'a vu dans les
premiers article de ce texte de loi on
n'y reviendra pas les statuts sont très
divers si son employeur ne veut pas le
régulariser donc les régularisations qui
se font aujourd'hui notamment au nom de
la circulaire bals je rappelle qu'elles
se font d'ailleurs essentiellement sur
le volet famille 23000 personnes plutôt
que sur volet de travail 7000 personnes
par an vous ne pouvez pas régulariser
une personne dit le code du travail si
l'employeur ne permet pas la
régularisation s'il ne signe pas le
SERFA qui permet la régularisation voilà
pourquoi des gens sont parfois devant
les
préfectures parfois soutenu par des élus
parfois soutenu par des syndicats par
des associations pour être régularisé il
n'y a pas de régularisation malgré une
volonté politique ou préfectorale parce
que la loi est au-dessus évidemment de
la volonté préfectorale ministérielle
donc la première volonté du gouvernement
était de mettre fin à à ce ce ce servage
d'un temps moderne que
l'employur pouvait s'opposer à la
régularisation de son employé qui
pourtant demandait la régularisation et
pourquoi il s'y opposé il s'y opposait
pas pour des raisons évidemment de
respect absolu du de la lutte contre
l'irrégularité puisque sinon il aurait
pas embauché son son employé sinon il
l'aurait s'en serait séparé rapidement
bien sûr
il le fait parce qu'il ne veut pas qu'on
découvre sans doute qu'il emploie
lui-même des personnes irrégulières et
qu' en a pas qu'une et qu'il faut faire
le contrôle et que l'inspection du
travail et d'autres font ce travail de
contrôle et effectivement c'est très
cohérent avec l'un article qui va
arriver que malheureusement la
commission des lois a supprimé on en
reparlera plus tard ce soir ou demain
qui est la sanction administrative
extrêmement forte contre l'entreprise
qui embauche des irréguliers de façon
évidente et sans avoir été omé par ses
salariés donc notre dispositif
gouvernemental est en premier lieu c'est
ça en premier lieu l'article 3 la
possibilité législative de faire sauter
si jeux dire ce verrou du Code du
travail régulariser quelqu'un sans son
employeur deuxièmement il
avait comme objectif et il a toujours
comme objectif le fait de régulariser
des personnes dans certaines conditions
qui souvent sont dans ce qu'on appelle
les niniis ni expulsable ni
régularisable pas expulsable parce que
évidemment leur vie privée est familiale
est désormais en France ça fait très
longues années qui sont venus en France
la grande moitié des personnes que nous
avons à constater sont là depuis plus de
10 ans du territoire national ça date
pas du quinquen d'Emmanuel Macron ni du
second ni du premier mais pas
régularisable parce queils sont dans les
régularités et que aucun texte de loi ne
permet de le faire parfois un peu la
circulaire Vals mais pas totalement
notamment sur les questions que j'ai
évoqué et comme ils sont souvent
employés dans des métiers dit en tension
où là le chômage qui n'est pas le refuge
en se disant il y a des réguliers qui
sont au chômage où il y a des Français
qui sont au chômage formonsles pour les
mettre évidemment c'est une bonne
réflexion que partage le gouvernement
dans les métiers d'entention dans
certaines zones géographiques dit
l'article 3 c'est métiers en tenstion et
zon géographiqu tendu donc ce n'est pas
partout sur le territoire national c'est
pas un endroit où il y a beaucoup de
chômage répondons à certains critères
depuis plus de 3 ans sur le territoire
national euh nous pouvions imaginer leur
régularisation avec en effet une
prescription le préfet doit alors
régulariser un titre de séjour d'un an
d'un an qui n'ouvre pas droit au
roupement familial c'est exprimé
expressis verbis et par ailleurs une
clause de cette loi s'arrêté en 2026 ce
qui évitait tout appel d' même si j'ai
eu du mal évidemment dans le débat
médiatique à le démontrer parce que la
caricature était plus facile puisque
c'était évidemment une clause de 3 ans
sur le territoire national qui s'arrêta
en 26 puisque nous étions à la fin de
l'année 23 il était évident que ces
personnes n'étaient pas concernées
personne pouvait venir en France en
imaginant trouver cette régularisation
ceci dit l'important comme je me suis
déjà exprimé c'est l'esprit de compromis
que veut le gouvernement pour avoir
l'essentiel de ce qu'il demande une
mesure de régularisation de personnes
qui travaillent dans notre pays sur dans
notre pays depuis très longtemps et dont
les patrons ne veulent pas les
régulariser parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
signerf pour pas qu'on découvre le
Potose nous avons euh entendu le
compromis qui a trouvé la majorité
sénatoriale que nous appelions de nos
vœux nous avons eu un amendement hier
soir il est celui qui va faire naître le
4 bis il est évidemment bien sûr
acceptable pour le gouvernement il y a
un certain nombre de dispositions qu'il
faudra sans doute il y a sans doute des
dispositions qu'il faudra modifier soit
parce qu'elles ont été me semble-t-il
écrites un peu à la hâte soit parce que
parfois elles sont plus larges que les
volontés gouvernementales je fai
remarquer avec un plaisir non fin à
Monsieur rillot que il il il régularise
plus de monde que nous l'aurions fait
puisque il il il évite que certaines
périodes de séjour régulier des durées
prises en compte pour apprécier ctistion
de conditions de séjour ne soit pas
concerné par exemple nous on avait dit
que la qualité de demandeur d'asile ne
rentrait pas ou que le titre de séjour
étudiant ou travailleurs saisoners ne
rentrait pas mais ceci étant dit je suis
sûr que vous votrez sous amendement du
Gouvernement qui complétera l'amendement
l'amendement qu' tout ça pour dire que
le gouvernement tout ça pour dire si si
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois je vous l'assure mais on en
parlera tout ça pour dire que le
gouvernement donnera un avis un avis de
sagesse euh sur
l'amendement sur l'amendement du 4 du 4
bis parce qu'évidemment il faudra que
nous le retravaillonss sans doute à
l'Assemblée nationale continuera à dire
qu'évidemment il tient son article 3 et
donc un avis évidemment qui permettrait
de garder l'article 3 tout en comprenant
qu'il y a un compromis politique à
obtenir ici au Sénat et donc demain
évidemment à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
l'engagement que je prends avec les
parlementaires mais sont évidemment
libres de modifier les choses je vrais
ici dire évidemment que c'est la
position entière monsieur canner du
gouvernement d'Olivier dusop qui
s'exprimait publiquement cet après-midi
mais je peux peut-être vous envoyer la
capture vidéo de son intervention si
vous n'avez pas eu le loisir d'avoir des
moyens de communication modernes dont
pourtant notre département du Nord Est
est pourvu et vous dire qu'évidemment je
je remercie de cet état d'esprit
remercier tous les groupes qui ont
participé et singulièrement le président
Marseille qui a porté des modifications
qui auraient pu être également
intéressantes et qui sont repris je
crois dans l'amendement proposé voilà
cet article 3 comme cet article 4 bis
n'est pas l'essentiel du texte de loi il
est un article sur 48 il concerne en
moyenne dans la version gouvernementale
7000 personnes par an et il était un
article qui se terminait de lui-même en
2026 je crois qu'il ne méritait pas ni
les bravos ni les aénissements de ceux
qui considéraent que c'était affreux ou
de ceux qui
considéraient de ceux qui considéraent
de ceux qui considéraent que c'était
l'alpha et l'oméga du texte c'est
évidemment une mesure qui avant tout
permet de régler des problèmes
individuels qui sont aujourd'hui
insolubles surtout féminin les problèmes
qui sont concernés ici c'est surtout des
femmes qui sont concerné par cet article
3 et 4 bis et surtout il nous permet de
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
de ceux qui embauchent des personnes de
façon irrégulière et j'espère que nous
mettrons ainsi fin un écosystème
irrégulé avec deux dispositions du texte
donc voilà madame la Présidente parce
que j'imagine qu'il aa beaucoup de prise
de parole la la la é clarté que voudrait
avancer le gouvernement sur les
propositions faites par le Sénat très
bien merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est désormais à monsie à Madame
Audry
linkeldde merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le
ministre il n'est pas simple de
s'exprimer sur cet article 3 quand je me
suis inscrite c'était probablement pas
tout à fait le même article 3 c'était en
tout cas celui que vient au départ de
son propos de présenter monsieur le
ministre depuis nous avons connu le
moment où l'article 3 et l'article 4 ont
été réservés puis le moment où ils ont
été déréservés puis le moment où ils
sont amendés pour se transformer en un
article 4 bis donc plutôt que de
d'essayer de commenter finalement un
article dont on ne sait plus très bien
le quel il est et ce qu' contient
précisément je vais euh plutôt dire ce
qui nous euh sur les bans des du groupe
socialiste nous paraissait intéressant
dans cet article puisqu'il fait partie
des des rares sujets sur lesquels on
pouvait considérer qu'il y avait des
avancées positives dans ce projet de loi
immigration et et intégration ce ce
qu'il nous semble à nous c'est que en
effet euh des travailleurs euh sans
papiers mais en France depuis au moins 3
ans travaillant depuis plusieurs mois
déjà exerçant des métiers dont nous
avons tous besoin dans notre société
auxiliaire de vie gardien agent de de
nettoyage cuisinier plongeur voilà que
ces travailleursl euh pouvaient avoir
droit à une carte de séjour temporaire
sans avoir à en passer par l'analyse
individuelle d'un préfet mais de plein
droit parce que la loi reconnaît la
contribution qui est à l'URE à notre
économie et à notre société voilà ce que
nous défendons voilà ce que nous allons
continuer à défendre y compris avec des
amendements qui permettront peut-être
d'aller encore plus loin que ce que
prévoyait l'article 3 et ce que prévoira
l'article 4 bis merci Madame madame
ponmonge merci madame la Présidente
alors depuis des semaines des
travailleurs sans papiers sont en grève
dans une trentaine de sites
d'île-de-fance dont ceux des JO ils
manifestent devant les agences d'intérim
les entreprises de nettoyage il demande
à ce que la raison et la justice
voudraiit que nous demandions à savoir
la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papier l'article 3 qui
reçoit tant de critiques sur les bands
de la droite réduit pourtant toujours
ces travailleurs dont une grande partie
ça a été dit sont employés sur des
métiers difficiles et dangereux à une
partie une immigration toujours choisie
comme entériné après les grandes grèves
des S papiers de 2008 par Nicolas
Sarkozi et dont la liste des 30 métiers
a ensuite été formalisé par la
circulaire Vals bris sortefeu dis disait
la loi que j'ai fait voter prévoit de
régulariser au cas par cas dans des
secteurs connaissant de graves pénuries
de main d'œuvre donc rien de nouveau
mais c'est encore trop il faut durcir
durcir et surtout laisser les
régularisations à la main des employeurs
même à postériori cette politique
d'immigration jetable est à l'œuvre est
à l'œuvre depuis 15 ans et la droite
trouve encore trop l'xiste l'article 3
qui voulait effectivement l'adoucir
c'est une politique adapté en plus de
son cooup humain comme le constate
Emeline zoubé sociologue au CNRS la
liste des métiers en tenstion tel
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui ne correspond
pas du tout au postees qu'occupent les
sans papiers problème que faites-vous
des travailleurs sans papier qui ne sont
pas donc dans les soi-disant métiers en
tension et que ferez-vous de ceux qui ne
le qui le seront puis qui ne le seront
plus de ceux qui travaillent depuis des
années et font tenir les entreprises et
des secteurs entiers et parti participe
ainsi à l'effort collectif ce que nous
devrions défendre ce que les écologistes
défendent la position raisonnable et
humaniste c'est la régularisation de
tous les travailleurs sans papierers de
plein droit avec un titre de séjour
durable nous en sommes loin et même
limité aux emplois vacants la droite
trouve que c'est encore trop par pure
idéologie merci madame pensong monsieur
le Président canner merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la
ministre j'ai dans les mains le projet
de loi initial contrôler l'immigration
améliorer l'intégration et j'ai pris
l'exposé des motifs que vous avez donc
validé avec Monsieur lopt monsieur le
ministre
euh concernant l'article 3 la carte de
séjour temporaire mention travail dans
des métiers en tension relèverait de la
seule initiative du travailleur étranger
elle serait délivrée de plein droit sous
réserve de la preuve apportée par tout
moyen d'une ancienneté de résidence sur
le territoire et cetera et cetera
c'était l'esprit de l'article 3 qui
manifestement est aujourd'hui dénaturé
et bien je tiens à vous dire que nous
nous opposerons à la dénaturation de
l'article 3 et aussi de l'article 4 au
passage dénaturation qui est résumé dans
le l'amendement créant un article 4 bis
dans ce projet de loi chers collègues
régulariser une personne qui vit en
France qui travaille B c'est tout
simplement reconnaître sa participation
à la vie de notre société et monsieur
dermanin a évoqué notre point commun il
y en a quand même à savoir d'être du
Nord combien de patrons que j'ai pu
rencontrer dans ma campagne électorale
comme d'autres ici pendant 5 semaines 6
semaines au mois d'août et de septembre
me disait mais donnez-nous finalement
l'encadrement juridique qui nous permett
de donner une vie correcte à celles et
ceux qui enrichissent notre notre pays
je ne suis pas dans le Patos je suis
dans la réalité économique et même sur
les bandes droitees ici vous savez qu'il
y a cette demande qui qui est existe
alors c'est vrai que nous nous voulons
une société un vivre ensemble dans une
république inclusive et tout ce qui ira
contre les principes finalement généreux
du projet de loi initial et bien nous
nous y opposerons avec force avec
vigueur nous voulons des personnes
autonomes intégrées dans notre
République et même si elles sont
étrangères elles méritent notre
considération et encore une fois notre
bienveillance voilà l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous porterons nos amendements à
vos différentes propositions merci
monsieur le Président Madame
Floren merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames madame et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous l'avons affirmé dès la
discussion générale nous n'avons jamais
été des fétichistes de l'article 3 notre
démarche est pragmatique guidée par la
volonté de parvenir à un compromis
satisfaisant savoir si le dispositif est
à l'article 3 après l'article 3 le 4 ou
le 13 nous nous importe peu encore une
fois nous ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscité par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
fallait-il créer un nouveau titre de
séjour avec des critères ouvrant un
droit à régularisation dans les métiers
en tension non et ce n'est pas nouveau
c'est ce que nous répétons depuis des
mois notre ligne sur le sujet est
parfaitement claire et n'a pas bougé le
plus efficace nous l'avions déjà dit est
de comme aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'appréciation des préfets dans une
gestion des dossiers au cas par cas y
compris dans les métiers en tenstion
c'est ce que prévoit l'amendement que
nous avions déposé à l'article 3 que
nous avons déposé à l'article 3
l'article 3 en tant que tel pose un
problème un problème symbolique pas de
problème mettons cette disposition
ailleurs dans le texte s'appuyons
clairement sur le dispositif de notre
amendement la commission nous propose
aujourd'hui une disposition i en
additionnel à l'article 4 et bien mes
chers collègues sans surprise cela nous
convient
parfaitement nous sommes attachés au
fond de cet article pas à la forme comme
nous le souhaitons le dispositif proposé
prévoit bien de modifier le régime
applicable en matière d'autorisation de
travail cela a été rappelé un salarié
sans papier qui souhaite régulariser sa
situation doit recueillir l'accord de
son employeur à travers la signature
d'un formulaire SERFA et de pouvoir afin
de pouvoir proposer sa son demander son
titre de séjour nous souhaitons pas que
cette disposition soit maintenue c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut prévoir
sa suppression et la suppression de
l'accord préalable donc dans la solution
retenu extrm excusez-moi madame la
Présidente par la commission n aura ni
d'appel d'air ni de dénis de réalité
merci Madame Floren monsieur
brossant merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le
ministre je voudrais exprimer ici les
les les regrets de notre groupe nous
n'avons jamais considéré que l'article 3
était était une panassée nous avions
plein de propositions à faire pour pour
en améliorer la rédaction pour en pour
en étendre
l'application mais tout le monde a bien
compris le sort qui sera réservé à cet
article 3 par la majorité sénatoriale je
dis des regrets parce que cet article 3
permettait au
moins de commencer à sortir d'une forme
d'hypocrisie qui fait que des milliers
de personnes qui travaillent en France
qui se lèv tôt qui se couche tard qui
bosse dans des métiers
pénibles le font aujourd'hui sans papier
et donc sans droit des personnes qui
bossent dans le ménage qui travaillent
comme
hboueur qui travaill dans les travaux
publics et qui bien souvent payent des
impôts et paye des cotisations sociales
et de fait la circulaire Val avait des
éléments qui à nos yeux étaient quand
même un peu absurde que pour régulariser
un travailleur sans papier on a besoin
de l'autorisation de l'employeur
c'est-à-dire de celui qui bien souvent
siamment a fait le choix d'embaucher un
travailleur sans papier on se retrouve
avec un travailleur sans papier qui doit
quander auprès de son employur une
autorisation remplir un SERFA qui lui
permette d'être régularisé tout cela
avait quelque chose d'absurde cet
article 3 nous permettait d'avancer et
je regrette que la majorité sénatoriale
ait fait le choix de sacrifier cet
élément et de sortir de cette manière-là
de de l'hypocrisie un regret donc mais
une satisfaction malgré tout c'est que
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion le
prouvent la majorité des Français qui
pourtant sont dur sur les questions
d'immigration sont favorables à la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier et je pense que cela témoigne que
cela vous déplaise c'est une chose mais
c'est la réalité et à un moment donné il
faut être capable de regarder la réalité
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick
jade merci merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues on arrive à un point clé de ce
débat c'est
évident monsieur le ministre quand vous
avez présenté ce projet de loi avec une
formule un peu infantilis mais on va la
reprendre ce projet de là ce projet de
loi c'est pour être méchant avec les
méchants et gentil avec les gentils le
résultat c'est que ce projet de loi
c'est simplement être méchant avec les
gentils quand on regarde vous n'avez pas
arrêté ce ce projet de loi et ce débat
n'est construit que sur des mensonges et
des
contrevérités le mot clé le mot clé que
vous avez incontestablement réussi à
faire passer dans l'opinion publique
c'est appel d'air pas une étude pas un
expert pas un chef d'entreprise pas un
syndicaliste ne confirme l'appel d'air
l'immigration serait incontrôlable c'est
faux aucune statistique ne le valide il
faudrait revenir sur la dignité des
personnes attaquer les étudiants refuser
de soigner les immigrés il faudrait
limiter les mariages mix et le regoup
familial et c'est comme ça qu'on
répondrait à un enjeu de
société vous êtes à côté ce débat est un
débat parallèle est un monde parallèle
par rapport à la réalité les Françaises
et les Français les
entreprises les
citoyens du Sénat ils attendent que nous
répondions sur le fond à la question de
l'immigration et aujourd'hui c'est un
projet de loi du désordre et du mensonge
parce que laisser des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans l'illégalité
dans l'indignité dans la précarité alors
qu'ils construisent la France
avec merci la parole est à Monsieur
benaroche la parole est à Monsieur
benaroche monsieur
benaroche
j' le
silence monsieur benaroche et à lui seul
merci beaucoup je vous remercie madame
la
Présidente je voulais faire une petite
jeunesse de cette histoire de ce projet
de loi en fait monsieur le
ministre je vous rappelle quand même le
titre premier s'appelle assurer une
meilleure intégration des étrangers par
le travail nous sommes rencontrés
d'ailleurs au tout début début comme
vous avez rencontré tous les présidents
de groupe du Sénat accompagné d'un
certain nombre de sénateurs j'étais donc
avec le président Guillaume gotard
lorsque vous nous avez reçu avec Olivier
du sopt qui à ce moment-là était souvent
présent on l'attend peut-être je ne sais
pas et vous nous avez expliqué quelle
était quelles étaient vos intentions
monsieur le ministre et nous vous avons
dit avec Guillaume Gard que nous les
comprenions nous pouvions même envisager
que nous pourrions apporter un certain
nombre d'idées supplémentaires à cell
que vous aviez déjà évoqué qui a été
rappelé tout à l'heure pour une
meilleure intégration par le
travail en France des
immigrés après cette après ce début
monsieur Darmanin cette loi est arrivée
au Sénat elle a été profondément
modifiée par la commission des Lois du
Sénat puis elle a été stoppée net dans
son élor par le gouvernement euh on a
entendu qu' en aurait finalement deux et
puis après on a dit qu' en aurait zéro
et puis peut-être qu'il en aurait une
une et puis peut-être il en aurait une à
un moment donné on ne sait pas quand et
nous sommes retrouvés devant le retour
au projet de loi voté par le Sénat à la
version
sénatoriale maintenant et la principale
différence c'est que maintenant la
négociation qui avait lieu avant a eu
lieu en direct live au Sénat et que donc
en fait vous l'avez dit vous-même d'un
projet qui était fait pour favoriser
l'intégration par le travail en France
il il en est ressorti un projet qui a
pour seul intérêt pour vous d'arriver à
un consensus parce que ce qui compte
pour vous c'est l'esprit de compromis
c'està-dire le consensus politicien
voilà ce qui est devenu le projet de loi
travail et intégration par par le
travail monsieur le ministre et monsieur
le sénateur monsieur benaroch la parole
est maintenant à Madame
Vogel merci madame la Présidente alors
en effet on arrive au moment de la
discussion de l'article qui au fond
était là pour servir les éléments de
langage du gouvernement nous avons un
projet équilibré il marche sur deux
jambes la jambe des horreurs et la
chambre des douceurs alors les horreurs
on a vu hein depuis lundi suppression de
laame durcissement du regroupement
familial décalage des allocations
familiales et cetera et cetera et puis
là on devait arriver à la jambe des
douceurs très faible hein il s'agissait
de donner un peu de dignité à un peu de
personnes pendant un peu de temps
c'était ça l'article 3 et là il est
question de l'amputer cette jambe alors
de la part des républicains et de la
majorité sénatoriale ça surprendra
personne la véritable information de ce
soir c'est celle qui vient du
gouvernement en réalité quand vous nous
dites que vous êtes prêt à donner un
avis de sagesse sur la suppression de
l'article 3 qui était l'article que vous
vendiez partout dans la presse pour
expliquer vous avez donné un avis de
sagesse sur l'amendement euh 655 qui est
un amendement de suppression de
l'article 3 monsieur le ministre ou
alors j'ai mal compris j'espère vous le
corrigerez la véritable information de
ce soir c'est que le gouvernement
préfère perdre l'honneur pour garder une
loi que de perdre un
vote pour garder la
face merci Madame Vogel le président
retaillot bien oui merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre bien sûr
que c'est un moment clé de la discussion
de ce texte et depuis le départ nous
avons dit notre opposition à l'article 3
et à l'article 4 et ce soir j'espère
bien qu'ils seront
supprimés alors c'est extraordinaire
monsieur le ministre vous manquez pas
d'air je sais qu'en politique le culot
c'est souvent une qualité je le
reconnais et vous voulez faire croire
que le dispositif proposé par la
majorité sénatoriale c'est l'équivalent
finalement de du dispositif que vous
proposie mais queeneni ou alors les
groupes de gauche se trompent pourquoi
est-ce que tous les groupes de gauche
montent au créneau parce que eux voit
bien la comparaison et ils savent bien
que la proposition qu'on fait c'est pas
du tout la proposition initiale qui
était le sommet le paroxisme de la
macronie le en même temps pourquoi on
s'opposait et pourquoi c'est beaucoup
plus restrictif parce que vous l'article
3 notamment c'est un droit automatique
vous fraudez et plus longtemps vous
fraudez plus la fraude est dissimulée et
plus ça vous génère et plus la fraude
est créatrice de droit d'un droit
opposable d'un droit automatique que
même l'administration ne pourra pas
stopper B nous on voulait pas et c'est
pour ça qu'on va le supprimer et qu'on
le remplace par un durcissement de la
circulaire et votre dispositif n'est pas
quantifiable mais c'était des dizaines
de milliers sans doute de régularisation
le nôre est beaucoup beaucoup plus
quantifiable et surtout il est tenable
il est tenable parce qu'il ne crée pas
un droit autom
et nous allons durcir ce qu'on appelle
la circulaire V mais ça sera pour les
médecins en tenstion et si d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre si d'ailleurs il y
avait un sous-amendement pour le
restreindre encore plus moi j'invite les
collègues de gauche et de droite à le
voter même si ça vient de vous
voyez merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur
Dosu merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais dire que je suis d'accord avec
le ministre quand il a justifié la
désertion ou la capitulation du du
gouvernement en race campagne
d'aujourd'hui par quand il a dit cet
article 3 ne méritait pas grand-chose
c'est la réalité nous aussi nous
pensionons qu'il méritait pas
grand-chose puisque nous les écologistes
nous sommes attachés à la valeur du
travail à l'égalité des droits et donc à
la régularisation des travailleurs ceux
qui travaillent ici ceux qui parfois
payent des cotisations ici ont droit au
même droit que les autres travailleurs
ici la droite préfère les clandestins et
le travaille au noir comme ça vient
d'être dit par le président retaillot
et donc pourtant le Président retaillot
il y a quelques jours encore nous disait
on veut plus d'article 3 du tout on ne
veut même plus de jeu de bon tau avec
une réécriture de l'article 3 ailleurs
dans le texte qu'est-ce que nous allons
faire aujourd'hui un jeu de bonne tau on
va supprimer cet article 3 on va le
réécrire en pire certes mais on va quand
même le réécrire en dessous et donc il
n'y a pas que le certainement
pas
et donc on régissre on réécrit un
dispositif pire pour les travailleurs
pire que le dispositif existant c'est
déjà un B à la parole monsieur
benénaroche laissez-le parler et donc ça
a été dit le texte qui va sortir à la
fin de ce Sénat c'est le cabinet des
horreur c'est en réalité l'accord scellé
non pas entre le LR les centristes et le
gouvernement c'est l'accord scellé entre
LR et le rassemblement national puisque
tout ce qu'on trouve là dans ce texte
c'est le programme du rassemblement
national voir le programme du Front
national historique des années 90 c'est
le pire de ce qu'on peut trouver et les
digons sauté les centristes se sont fait
engloutir dans dans cette calamité au
revoir merci Monsieur dessus madame de
La
Gonterie merci madame la
Présidente chers collègue monsieur le
ministre j'ai fait partie d'une d'un
rassemblement de par parlementaire de
toute tendance politique y compris des
membres du parti Renaissance qui ont
estimé
effectivement nécessaire de venir au
soutien de ce qui était l'article 3
pourquoi tout simplement pour mettre un
terme à ce qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure le mot a été utiliser
l'hypocrisie nous savons tous vous savez
tous que nous avons parmi nos proches ou
dans nos villes des personnes qui
travaillent dans des restaurants qui
travaillent dans des supermarchés qui
travaillent parfois dans le BTP et qui
sont en situation irrégulière donc à
partir de là deux solutions soit vous
faites en sorte que ces personnes
quittent le
territoire soit vous considérez ce qui
est le cas des syndicats d'employeurs du
syndicat de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration qu'il y a besoin de ces
personnes pour faire tourner
l'économie donc y a-t-il un intérêt
alors que nous en avons besoin à
maintenir ces personnes dans
l'illégalité donc dans la précarité on a
beaucoup parlé de la Vals elle avait un
défaut majeur c'est l'autorisation de
l'employeur j'indique nous y reviendrons
tout à l'heure que l'amendement qui est
proposé par les rapporteurs réintroduit
l'intervention de l'employeur et que
donc nous aurons à y revenir mais elle
avait un deuxième
défaut c'est que
elle laissait effectivement le libre
arbitre du préfet et ce que vous savez
sans doute monsieur le ministre mais il
faudrait le reconnaître ou plutôt y
faire face c'est que les préfectures
avaient un comportement totalement
hétérogène et que donc on ne pouvait pas
considérer et c'est sans doute pour cela
que votre texte utilisait le fait que
cette carte était octroyée de droit et
elle avait un plus cette circulaire Vals
que n'a pas l'amendement qui est proposé
c'est qu'elle s'appliquait dans tous les
secteurs professionnels alors
aujourd'hui nous ne parlons que des
métiers en tension donc il faudra bien y
revenir tout à l'heure merci donc voilà
pourquoi nous soutenions et voilà
pourquoi nous allons combattre ce qui
est proposé de manière trop restrictive
aujourd'hui merci madame de la GRI
madame la Présidente cuerman
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je crois
qu'effectivement et en toute
sincérité l'article tel qu'écrit
initialement et celui qui va nous être
proposé n'est pas tout à fait le même
d'ailleurs s'il était nous n serions pas
là et donc je je je crois que cela a
fait déjà couler beaucoup d'encre fait
parler beaucoup de personnes en revanche
ce qui nous satisfaisait et je l'ai déjà
évoqué dans cette cette vision de
l'article 3 initiale était effectivement
qu'elle
mettait un stop à une des vraie
difficulté de la circulaire Vals comme
ça a déjà été dit qui per qui rendè
finalement les employeurs qui
employaient eux-mêmes des travailleurs
sans papiers comme ceux qui donnaient
autorisation ou non à leur
régularisation et l'on comprend là quand
même toute la difficulté il compris même
philosophique à accepter une telle
démarche je crois que nous avons
finalement un petit débat de méthode
parce que
j'entends la la crainte si je peux le
dire ainsi de de certains nombreux
d'ailleurs ce soir d'une d'une porte
ouverte d'un appel d'air qui ferait
venir des dizaines des centaines des
milliers je laisse chacun apprécier
l'échelle de de trailleur sans papier
mais je crois qu'on on se trompe de
débat ces femmes et ces hommes
aujourd'hui sont présents ils sont
présents sur notre territoire notre
collègue précédemment de l' Atlantique
le rappelait ils sont aujourd'hui celles
et ceux qui travaillent dans nos
industries celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans des dans les
entreprises agricoles celles et ceux qui
construisent et qui rendent possible le
Paris des Jeux Olympiques 2000 2024 pour
pour l'été prochain donc je crois très
sincèrement que ça ne fera pas un appel
d'air cela permettra justement d'
appquer la loi et je ne doute pas mes
chers collègues comme vous l'avez dit
que vous aurez cette même vigilance pour
sanctionner ces employeurs qui
consciemment emploie aujourd'hui de
manière irrégulière des sans papiers
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
Gontard merci Madame la madame la
Présidente moi je voudrais effectivement
qu'on se repose peut-être la question de
de ce qu'est un une travailleuse ou un
travailleur sans papier parce que j'ai
l'impression que voilà
on parle comme ça c'est quoi une
travailleuse ou un travailleur sans
papier ce sont des travailleurs des
travailleuses tout simplement ce sont
des gens qui font un travail qui
exercent une activité qui permettent à
notre pays de fonctionner qui ont permis
à notre pays de fonctionner notamment
pendant le covid qui permettent que
notre pays puisse fonctionner
encore c'est quand vous allez dans un
hôtel des femmes des hommes qui vont
faire le nettoyage ce sont des gens qui
vont faire toutes les activités dont
nous avons besoin alors oui elles n'ont
pas de papier elles n'ont pas de papier
elles n'ont pas de papier mais par
contre elles ont la possibilité de
travailler c'est peut-être cette
question là qu'il faudrait se poser
pourquoi
on cette possibilité de travailler
qu'est-ce que nous demandons tout
simplement cette possibilité ce droit au
travail et oui nous nous demandons un
droit au travail
inconditionnel pourquoi parce que le
travail c'est un c'est effectivement
l'émancipation c'est un lieu
d'intégration et donc nous demandons ce
droit au travail inconditionnel qui
permettrait d'éviter d'ailleurs qu'on
discute de tout ce qu'on a dû discuter
de ce travail illégal de comment on
empêche ce travail illégal on a besoin
que ces salariés ils soient encadrés et
moi je me demande quand même une chose
quand j'écoute les débats depuis 2 jours
qu'est-ce qui arrive à la droite
qu'est-ce qui vous arrive hier ça a été
une descente en règle de la valeur
famille
alors la famille ça ne serait plus le
lieu de l'émancipation ça serait plus le
lieu de l'intégration il faudrait tout
faire tout mettre en œuvre pour éviter
la famille et puis là aujourd'hui ce
soir c'est la valeur travail celle dont
vous nous avez parlé cette valeur
travail que vous ne souhaitez pas qui ne
serait plus justement la valeur sur lequ
il faudraitiser merci beaucoup merci la
parole est à Monsieur
DC tout le monde
ici c'est que notre société ne
fonctionnerait pas sans ces dizaines de
milliers de travailleurs sans papier
tout le monde le sait y compris la
puissance économique touristique de la
France et tout particulièrement de la
région parisienne de tous ceux qui sont
effectivement dans les restaurants dans
l'accueil et qui participent de la
richesse de la France
sans sans ces travailleurs la France
serait une puissance affaiblie que la
droite veuille une France affaiblie ça
nous étonne un peu mais vous êtes assez
constant dans l'effort Bruno rotaillot a
parlé de fraudeur c'est un terme qui
arrive dans le débat donc ces
travailleurs qui permettent d'augmenter
la richesse de la France sont en fait
des fraudeurs mais que que ceux qui les
embauchent eux ne sont pas vraiment des
fraudeurs puisque nous n'avons pas vu
arriver sur vos bancs des amendements
qui durciraient fortement les
législations pour s'attaquer
effectivement à ce petit patron de
restaurant qui aurait deux ou trois
salariés donc sans papier voir le grand
groupe industriel qui de filiale en
filiale a beaucoup beaucoup de
travailleurs sans papiier donc j'attends
vos amendements j'attends vos
amendements et puis il y a un dernier
fraudeur c'est quand même l'état parce
que l'État touche un certain nombre de
cotisations qui vont rester dans les
caisses de l'État par définition moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui vous participez à
droite de cette France du non droit qui
justement déstabilise la société
française je crois qu'effectivement
tolérer autant de non droit et se mettre
au service du renforcement du non drroit
vous devenez des gens extrêmement
déstabilisants pour la société française
alors que notre responsabilité
mon merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Yann
[Applaudissements]
chanrel merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues monsieur le ministre dans
votre projet de loi initialement comme
ça a été dit par plusieurs de mes
collègues c'était censé également
permettre d'améliorer l'intégration où
est depuis le début de la discussion de
ce texte un seul point une seule ligne
sur l'intégration nulle part justice
partout justice humanité nulle part
depuis le début depuis le début de ce
texte il y avait peut-être
éventuellement une petite ébauche bien
insatisfaisante bien évidemment à
travers cet article 3 qui permettrait de
régulariser des travailleurs que
vous-même hypocritement sur les bans de
la droite et c'est même le ministre
lui-même qui a dit qu'il avait une liste
de plusieurs parlementaires qui
eux-mêmes se rendent en compte de
l'utilité de ces travailleurs sans
papier bien évidemment puisque ils sont
dans les métiers les plus pénibles
demandent des régularisation vous le
demandez pas publiquement bien
évidemment mais vous le demandez parce
que vous-même vous avez conscience
qu'ils sont utiles dans notre pays et ça
serait à l'honneur de notre pays plutôt
que de passer notre temps depuis 20 ans
pour en faire de la chair à canon
électoral de taper sur l'immigré en
permanence ça ça divise notre pays ça ne
l'apèse pas vous divisez notre pays en
faisant une course à l'échalote
permanente derrière l'extrême droite je
pense que les grands républicains qui
vous ont CD je pense aurit honte de vous
aurit honte du débat tel qu'il se
déroule depuis le début de ce texte vous
allez finir par navoir de républicain
que le nom vous partez dans une pente
fatale plus vous irez vers l'extrême
droite plus elle progresse ça vous ne
faites que la renforcer en reprendant
les lbis le l'immigré c'est pas lui qui
c'est pas lui le problème c'est plutôt
la fiche de paix justement et la fiche
de paix c'est déjà de permettre la
régularisation de ces travailleurs qui
sont utiles qui participent pleinement à
l'économie de notre société ça serait
bien qu'àun moment donné la
représentation nationale est plutôt de
la reconnaissance pour eux plutôt que de
les montrer du doigt en
permanence merci la parole est au
président
bas vous me pardonnerez mes chers
collègues mais je trouve les postures
accusatoires et moralisatrice
parfaitement
déplacé que ceux qui défendent
l'idée que la fraude peut-être créatrice
de droit ne revendique pas pour leur
compte la morale et ne nous accuse pas
d'hypocrisie la deuxième
chose la deuxième chose que je veux dire
c'est que la solution de l'article 3
c'était la solution de la paresse de la
puissance publi c'est la solution de la
résignation à ne rien faire pour que les
po disponible soit pourvu soit par des
Français soit par des étrangers en
situation régulière la troisème chose
que je veux dire c'est
que créer un droit à la régularisation
comme le voulait le gouvernement et
comme l'a encore défendu le ministre
c'est quelque chose que nous ne pouvons
absolument pas accepter et qui nous
paraît totalement insoutenable que des
régularisations soi
par l'exercice d'un pouvoir
discrétionnaire de l'État pour
récompenser des conduites
exceptionnellement vertueuse et pour
permettre l'assimilation à la société
française d'un certain nombre
d'individus pourquoi pas mais créer un
droit opposable comme voulez le faire le
gouvernement ça c'est quelque chose que
nous ne pouvons en aucun cas accepter en
raison des principes qui sont les nôtres
et oui chers collègues chant des
principes républicains et j'aimerais
qu'il soit mieux partagé dans cette
assemblée monsieur bah monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Billac merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègu nous voici donc devant cet
article 3 et vous le savez au RDSE on
adore le
débat on aime le débat parce qu'on pense
que c'est
l'essence de la vie parlementaire
et au RDSE on aime les amendements parce
que c'est le travail parlementaire
d'amender un texte moi j'irai pas comme
mon collègue philiip bas dire que c'est
le texte de la paresse mais on est là
pour amender un texte imparfait pour
essayer de trouver une solution pour que
ce texte soit plus proche de la réalité
réponde aux attentes alors je vous
rappelle que mardi on va voter le budget
de la Sécurité sociale le PLFSS je crois
qu' un déficite c'est pas nouveau mais
ça y est toujours et et là alors on peut
être aveugle et tourner la tête mais le
nombre de travailleurs qui dans les chat
dans les arrières boutiques de
restaurant ou sur les chantiers du
BTP sont des travailleurs
étrangers en une situation irrégulière
si on les arrête ça va faire drôle ça
existe il faut pas mettre la tête dans
le sable comme les autruches ça existe
et donc il faut le changer alors j'ai
entendu la critique sur l'ut automatisme
c'est peut-être vrai cet automatisme
peut présenter des dispositifs contraire
à ce qu'on attend dans cette loi
intégration et immigration et donc là il
y a une solution j'entendu dire le
préfet les délivrera mais je à la
préfecture il y en a une pile de maîtres
à la préfecture de Montpellier d'attente
de traitement donc où il faut mettre un
moyen préfect ou alors plutôt que le
préfet exruise tous les dossiers donner
au préfet un droit de véau peut-être
pour réduire moi je crois que vous avez
parlé de pars tout à l'heure supprimé
par un amendement et simplement cet
article au lieu de l'amender sur le fond
me semble aussi une solution assez
facile merci Monsieur bac la parole est
à Monsieur
sourk merci madame la Présidente
l'article 3 est mort vive l'article 3
voilà donc le résultat des tractations
de la journée si l'amendement que la
majorité sénatoriale présentera tout à
l'heure limite à la marge la scandaleuse
campagne de régularisation massive que
proposait le gouvernement il ne règle
rien le problème fondamental de cette
injustice en ouvrant la possibilité
d'une régularisation à postériori d'un
étranger ne respectant pas la loi
employée par un patron lui aussi dans
l'illégalité vous laissez ouvertes les
fenêtres d'une maison déjà offerte aux
80 aucune justification économique ou
sociale ne peut soutenir votre
amendement 2 millions de chômeurs 3
millions de sous-employés l'économie
française peut répondre sans immigration
à cette prétendue crise de main d'œuvre
qui n'est qu'une crise des salaires et
des conditions de travail ne vous en
déplaisent les Français ne sont sont pas
des féignants mais les Français ne
peuvent pas continuer à travailler dans
des métiers difficiles pour des salaires
de misère à des dizaines de kilomètres
de chez eux avec un coût de l'énergie et
les carburants qui continuent d'exploser
et des conditions de logement qui se
dégradent encore dans déplais à la
gauche la régularisation soutient à
l'exploitation de personnes en situation
précaire et fatalement en situation de
faiblesse il valide à postériori des
pratiques condamnables au premier sens
du terme puisqu est légal la gauche
continue de constituer son armée de
réserve électorale la même que Marx
appelait l'armée réserve du capitalisme
puisqueen plus de cela c'est le dumping
social qui s'organise avec une pression
à la baisse sur les salaires ne soyez
pas naïf à ces régularisations
succéderont de nouvelles situations
clandestines puisqu'elles en arrangent
certains et ni la situation des
travailleurs français ni celle de ceux
venus d'ailleurs dont on fait des
esclaves nous s'amélioreront nous
dénonçons cette capitulation qui en plus
préserve la responsabilité du politique
en se défensant encore sur les préfets
nous aurions pu considérer le vote de ce
projet de loi si l'article 3 avait été
est purement simplement supprimé sans
contrepartie à nos yeux il n'est plus
aujourd'hui défendable je vous remercie
merci Monsieur spinner
oui madame le Président Monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président messieur
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
nous défendons la valeur du travail et
vous devriez vous
interroger vous devriez vous
interroger seul monsieur spiner a la
parole merci vous devriez vous
interroger sur le fait que des emplois
ne sont pas pourvus par nos compatriotes
est-ce que c'est l' bararrtion des
salaires est-ce que c'est le manque de
formation tout ça pose un certain nombre
de problèmes que vous ne voulez pas voir
je vous invite à relire les propos de
Monsieur George Marchet lorsqu'il
parlait de
l'immigration mais j'en viens à ce que
vous essayez de faire passer comme idée
c'est-à-dire qu'il y aurait une sorte de
bonne taux juridique que l'article 3 que
nous abrogons et l'article 3 reconstitué
serait sur jumeau s jumelle et bien non
parce que qu'est-ce que voulait créer le
gouvernement il voulait créer le droit
opposable c'est ce qui vous arrange
c'est-à-dire que finalement votre vision
c'est puisque nous ne pouvons rien
laissons faire laissons aggraver la
crise laissons aggraver le sentiment
alors on peut penser on peut penser
comme Monsieur jade que l'immigration ne
pose aucun problème mais manifestement
nous ne vivons pas dans le même monde
nous ce que nous demandons c'est la
différence
entre lorsque la politique refuse en
réalité de céder à l'administration et
nous nous exerçons le pouvoir et c'est
de dire c'est l'autorité qui décide qui
peut être régularisé et ça n'est pas le
droit opposable c'est ça toute la
différence entre le droit opposable et
la volonté politique de contrôler oui
nous voulons contrôler l'immigration
pour que les gens la dignité des
personnes ce n'est pas de leur dire
venez en France restez dans la
clandestinité parce que plus tard vous
serez régulariséie merci Monsieur
spinner la parole est à Monsieur
salvoldelli Merci monsieur ravier vous
n'avez pas la
parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je dire juste un petit mot sur
la l'intervention précédente mon cher
collègue vous avez de la mémoire
politique si vous vous rappelez bien
vous avez cité George Marchet je vrais
vous dire que George Marchet il était
pas contre l'immigration mais il était
contre le capitalisme donc cette vérité
est
enite la deuxième la deuxième chose que
je voulais dire j'avais pas prévu vous
intervz làdessus la deè chose veux dire
c'est bon moi j'écoute de manière très
apaisée j'ai écouté le Président
retillot j'ai écouté le ministre
d'armalin mais vous dites la même chose
vous dites la même
chose je vous cite vous ne pouvez pas
régulariser une personne si l'employeur
ne le permet pas voilà vous dites la
même chose donc voilà il faut il y a
rien de grave je le dis avec
responsabilité honnêteté intellectuelle
alors c'est vrai pour le patron privé
plusieurs exemples ont été donnés là
c'est vrai dans le secteur marchand et
là le mot est peut-être puisqueil faut
tout apaiser je vais pas dire hypocrisie
donc j'ai une sorte de faux semblant
monsieur le ministre faut semblant quand
même parce que si on peut pas
régulariser une personne si l'employeur
ne le permet pas comment ça se fait que
dans mon département j'ai des
travailleurs sans papiers qui font un
piquet de greffe depuis 23 mois qui
était embauché par qui Chronopost la
poste dont le l'État et bien nos capital
vous connaissez vous êtes un des de ors
d'ordre et vous ne régularisez pas ces
travailleurs donc moi je vous le dis
aussi mes chers collègues dans ce débat
vif que je connais comme tout le monde
ici déjà depuis plusieurs heures et
journé moi je vous pose une question
pourquoi l'hémicycle le Parlement le
gouvernement
ignore que des centaines de milliers de
travailleurs sans papiers sont victimes
d'un conflit social que nous avons
décidé de totalement ignorer je vous
pose cette question de manière apaisée
et solennel merci Monsieur salbodelli
Madame gréhaume
oui en effet je vais venir en complément
de mon collègue moi ça me choque parce
que j'ai l'impression que les 100
papiers à force qu' qui travaill B on
les voit plus on pense pas qu'ils sont
sans papier et pourtant pourtant on a eu
quand même des articles à Paris au
fouets par exemple le fouets on croirait
pas qu'il y a des gens qui travaillent
là qui sont sans papier mais il y en
avait il y en a pas aussi dans la
filiale de la poste comme mon collègue
l'a dit là il y a des aides de l'État
notamment sur l'énergie pour P pour
poser des panneaux photovoltaïques vous
avez des étrangers chez vous il y en a
plein partout le pire de tout c'est que
je suis quand même étonnée c'est la
relation que vous avez avec le BDF parce
que normalement normalement les les
patrons d'entreprise moi j'ai discuté
avec des patrons d'entreprise est-ce
qu'ils me disent eux c'est qu'ils ont
personne pour répondre donc il prennent
les personnes qui sont volontaires qui
demandent pas et qui veulent travailler
et ils travaillent c'est ça la vérité
qu'il faut entendre ces personnes ils
sont là et ils travaillent et mon
collègue vient de vous le dire et il y
en a plein qui pourrai vous le dire on a
plein de situations où les gens
travaillent ils sont courageux ils sont
pas mendiants ils ne traînent pas dans
la rue à vous demander une pièce ils
sont là ils se lèvent tous les matins
malgré les conditions de vie donc je
pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut régulariser
tous ces personnesl et je vous prie de
croire discuz autour de vous avec le
patronat vous verrez un petit peu qui va
vous dire vous je pense que vous serez
très déçu bien merci Madame gréhaume la
parole est maintenant au ministre qui
fera preuve j'en suis sûr de
concision ah pardon pardon il y a encore
une intervention pardon monsieur le
ministre monsieur Ross je suis
désolée merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre désolé vousz 2
minutes de repos cet article 3 donc si
j'ai bien compris c'est le tournant des
débats alors parM tez-moi à ce moment
déjà de vous faire lecture d'un article
qui est sorti hier dans les écho au
moment où l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'immigration qui prévoit la
régularisation sous condition des
étrangers irréguliers dans les métiers
en tension à démarré en plinière au
Sénat l'étude apporte sa contribution au
débat elle juge que la France gagnerait
à s'ouvrir davantage aux minorités et
aux immigrants des pays comme le Canada
ou Singapour ont sugéré le sujet de
l'immigration de façon à rendre
acceptable pour leurs opinions publiques
et leur économie les échos on peut pas
considérer que c'est la presse de base
de propagande des partis de gauche et
cette étude elle provient de l'insed de
l'Institut Descartes et de Human Capital
leadership Institute alors Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous conduisez la
voiture gouvernementale et puisque cette
article 3 était le virage à gauche après
tous les virages à droite que nous avons
eu vous semblez vouloir tourner aussi à
droite dans le virage qui part à gauche
faites attention parce que vous
risqueriez d'amener le gouvernement et
la France à droite mais pas à droite
vers monsieur ravier à droite dans les
graviers et ce serait un déshonneur pour
la France très bien merci sur cette
pensée philosophique cette fois-ci
monsieur le ministre je vous donne la
parole merci la présidente ça vait le
coup ça vait le coup d'attendre en
effet quelques
mots quelques mots très rapides pour
répondre aux orateurs
nombreux pour essayer de de de peut-être
de préciser un certain nombre de
positions et puis ensuite j'espère que
nous pourrions avancer plus plus
rapidement en effet sur ce sujet qui est
cert important mais qui n'est pas encore
une fois nou cur du texte mais je
comprends que désormais il le soit bien
alors der je voudrais rappeler mes
positions de vote puisque madame ogogel
l'a manifestement mal entendu ou je me
suis mal exprimé je suis favorable à
garder l'article 3 tel qu'il est donc un
avis défavorable à l'amendement de
suppression et je dirais sagesse sur
l'amendement de repli ou l'article de
repli on l'app comme on veut le nouvel
article 3 appli 4 bis de la commission
des rapports donc voilà je voulais vous
le dire Madame la la sénatrice parce que
c'est peut-être pas la peine de mettre
de la confusion là où manifestement des
choses déjà assez
confuses d'abord mesames et messieurs
les sénateurs et je dis devant la PR
président de la commission des lois
qu'est-ce que j'ai essayé de faire
j'entends que le gouvernement a essayé
de faire un droit opposable
bon je voudrais dire à la Haute
Assemblée que non j'ai essayé de donner
au législateur les critères pour
régulariser les personnes donc je
constate pour avoir été parlementaire
depuis plus de 10 ans
désormais que en général les
parlementaires demandent à avoir les
règles pour faire à la place de l'État
et des préfets des directions
territoriales de l'État et là je viens
avec un texte de loi en disant à
l'Assemblée au Sénat en l'occurrence au
Sénat prenez les critères faites votre
travail de parlementaire il y a ceux qui
veulent plus régulariser il y a ceux qui
veulent moins régulariser puisque
manifestement tout le monde veut
régulariser puisquil y a donc un article
de régularisation bon donc si la vie est
ainsi faite et c'est normal parce que en
effet personne n'est vraiment hypocrite
ici et qui a effectivement beaucoup
d'intervention pour régulariser des
personnes et c'est heureux et c'est
heureux et c'est heureux bon mais après
ce qui est sûr c'est c'est évident que
quand on demande beaucoup de
régularisation et qu'on dit surtout pas
de régularisation le ministre
d'intérieur se dit tiens il doit avoir
un moment particulier le matin les
courriers ne ressemblent pas au débat
public du soir mais c'est comme ça je
dis au parlementaires prenez les
critères de régularité tion vous auriez
pu proposer de modifier l'article 3 avec
des critères beaucoup plus durs pas 3
ans sur le territoire national mais 5
ans 7 ans 10 ans pas pas les zones
géographiques tendu mais là où le
chômage est en dessous de 5 % on aurait
pu imaginer plein de critères monsieur
spinner Ava imaginé des quotas VO dans
son article qui remplacer le 3 vous ne
refusez manifestement de prendre ce
pouvoir parlementaire et vous dites
monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur
vraiment c'est vous allez vraiment
formidable on vous fait confiance
régulariser au cas par cas bon je
constate quand même que c'est assez rare
qu'une assemblée refuse de prendre les
pouvoirs et on aurait pu avoir un débat
politique très important pour savoir
s'il fallait plus ou moins régulariser
selon plus ou moins quel critère donc
j'espère que la prochaine fois qu'on
aura des débats pour me dire on veut
absolument que ce soit du domaine de la
loi on aura le souvenir de cette
question j'ai quand même l'impression
que l'hypocrisie arrange bien du monde
puisque du coup c'est ministre qui
régularis le parlementaire ou le maire
qui intervient et comme ça on peut dire
publiquement que non on na jamais fait
de droit opposable je trouve que
objectivement on parler d'hypocrisie ça
me paraissait pas très juste donc au
moins qu'on soit pas d'accord si on
n'est pas d'accord qu'on dise au moins
la vérité sur qu' fond de cet article
deuxièm je veux dire à à à la gauche de
cet hémicycle moi j'entends tous les
discours qu'on veut mais monsieur canner
me faites pas croire que si l'article 3
avait été voté vous ariez voté le texte
le Parti socialiste les vers le Parti
communiste ont dit dès le début on ne
votera jamais ce texte donc en fait ce
que vous souhaitez monsieur canner c'est
que le gouvernement n'it pas de texte
parce que ce que vous souhaitez c'est
que le gouvernement échoue et c'est norm
vous êtes dans l'opposition ne faites
pas croire non plus soyez pas vous aussi
dans l'hypocrisie si vraiment l'article
3 était voté on aurait voté les 47
autres articles bien sûr on aurait
soutenu le texte on aurait soutenu le
texte le texte du ministre de
l'Intérieur allons allons allons C c'est
une astuce monsieur canner qui qui qui
se voit mais non mais ne dites pas dans
ces cas-là que vous auriez voté le texte
ce n'est pas vrai vous l'avez fait dès
le début bien alors non mais dès le
début vous avez dit que vous voiez pas
le texte vous voudrez que je fasse
confiance à des gens qui quoi veulent la
du texte bon avouez que c'est une drôle
façon de faire de la
politique je fais avec l'état des choses
telleles qu'elles sont hein la
politique la politique c'est un idéal à
travers des réalités
bien est au ministre s'il vous plaît
merci d'écouter deuxièmement
deuxièmement ce qui est quand même très
intéressant c'est que vous annoncez donc
que vous voterez pas l'amendement de la
majorité sénatoriale parce qu'il ne va
pas assez loin donc vous refusez un
droit pour les personnes régularisées
donc vous avez entretenu quand vous bien
sûr mais je je et bien c'est tout à fait
vrai quelle est la grande quelle est la
grande avancée de l'article même 4 bis
proposé par la rapporteur c'est qu'enfin
on fait sauter ce servage du patron sur
l'employé non ce n'est pas faux non ce
n'est pas faux pour l'instant l'article
4 bis évoque le fait qu'il doit avoir
une vérification on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale mais c'est toujours mieux que
ce qui existe aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est un parti de gouvernement bah c'est
d'accepter quand même des petites
avancées donc donc par hypocrisie ou par
posture idéologique vous allez donc
refuser le petit plus pour les sans
papiers le petit plus pour les
travailleurs régularisés sous prétexte
que vous avez envie d' débat de posture
comme a dit président B vous êtes
totalement incohérent vous avez été en
responsabilité 10 ans une fois sous
monsieur Jospin une fois sous Monsieur
Hollande vous n'avez jamais régularisé
de plein droit les personnes vous n'avez
jamais fait sauter ces articles du code
du travail et vous avez tous soutenu la
circulaire de Monsieur Vals dès le début
du mandat de Monsieur Hollande sans
jamais peut-être pas les commun
sans jamais ri modifier donc alors votre
hypocrisie elle est la vre aujourd'hui
vous avez un gouvernement qui vient vous
proposer une modification ce que vous
souhaitez c'est lui tendre à pied pour
savoir s'il va se casser la tronche et
quand il propose une modification d'un
pas avancé vous dites ah non ah non ce
n'est pas assez propre manifestement ça
fait longtemps que vous avez quitté les
rivages des partis de gouvernement en
vous comportant comme ça et je trouve
que c'est et bien c'est tout à fait vrai
d'ailleurs votre alliance vous savez
bien avec Monsieur mélch et cette
démonstration voilà et vous le savez
parfaitement trièm il y a une cohérence
dans le texte du Gouvernement la
cohérence c'était l'article 2 l'article
3 l'article 5 l'article 8 je constate
que la majorité sénatoriale n'a pas été
cohérente à la commission des lois à la
commission des lois vous avez supprimé
l'article 2 qu'on a rétabli fort
heureusement hier merci à cette
assemblée l'article 5 et l'article 8 et
vous avez gardé l'article 3 parce que
l'article 3 l'enfire pour la majorité
sénatoriale a quand même passé la
commission des lois ça doit être pas si
dramatique que ça il on n pas trouvé on
n a pas trouvé une majorité mais bon je
ferme je ferme la parenthèse je je ferme
je ferme la parenthèse monsieur retillo
voilà donc on s'est aperçu que c'était
horrible mais 6 mois plus tard
évidemment bon donc c'est quoi l'article
5 c'est quoi l'article 8 l'article 5
c'est une filière d'immigration
irrégulière une filière d'immigration
irrégulière que nous avons tous créé qui
a été créé bien avant le président de la
République que on peut créer une
auto-entreprise sans papier nous allons
ensemble sur le site du ministère
deéconomie et des finances nous allons
ensemble sur le site ministère
d'économie et des Finances vous créez
votre autant d'entreprise sans papierers
donc vous créez des irréguliers qui en
effet payent des impôts qui en effet
payent des cotisation et au bout d'un
certain temps ils vont voir les préfets
pour dire on veut être régularisé
puisqu'on travaille comment la
commission des lois peut-elle à la fois
demander la nonrégularisation
automatique des S papiers et accepter de
ne pas restaurer cet article 5 donc je
le dis al pure cohérence effectivement
il doit avoir des limites à
interventions qui j'imagine sont
capitalistiques parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent avec une
manœuvre pas cher avec des
auto-entreprises dévoyées je dis à cette
assemblée vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
rétablir l'article 5 vous créez une
filière d'immigration irrégulière bien
plus grande que l'article 3 si vous
imaginez que c'est un droit opposable si
Monsieur rou é voqué des dizaines de
milliers ce que je réfute complètement
là ce sont pas des dizaines de milliers
c'est des dizaines de milliers par an
monsieur rotillot que vous avez laissé
faire par la suppression d'article 5
j'espère que vous reviendrez sur votre
texte et que vous voterez l'amendement
de restauration du gouvernement et
l'article 8 mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs l'article 8 c'était la
fermeture administrative des entre ise
qui embauché des personnes irrégulières
la commission des lois l'a supprimé donc
on a un article 3 qui n'a pas été
supprimé en commission des lois dont
aujourd'hui on me dit que c'est un droit
automatique alors que c'est pouvoir
donné au parlementaires et vous n'avez
pas supprimé l'article 8 vous n'avez pas
vous vous avez supprimé l'article 8
alors qu'on prévoyait la fermeture
administrative de l'entreprise le projet
du gouvernement était simple la
régularisation des personnes qui
demandaient leur régularisation pour
savoir qui embauchait des S papiers pour
pouvoir les faire fermer mais voilà donc
j'espère qu'il y aura une cohérence et
qu'on votera évidemment la restauration
du 5 et du 8 alors enfin je dire
quelques instants et j' terminerai par
là madame la Présidente Monsieur
rot moi je suis là pour le compromis
politique je dis tout le temps vous ne
vouliez pas d'article
régularisation monsieur le Président
vous ne vouliez pas d'article
régularisation vous avez obtenu un
compromis politique et c'est normal
c'est comme ça qu'on fonctionne dans une
assemblée parlementaire et c'est comme
ça qu'un gouvernement fonctionne quand
il une majorité relative
non mais vous ne vouliez pas de
régularisation vous êtes mis d'accord
vous êtes mis d'accord entre vous et
c'est bien naturel je suis le premier à
dire que c'est une bonne chose pour nous
tous que vous mettiez monsieur retillot
oui bien sûr il s'appelle cadbis ça il
est vraiment
différent monsieur rot vous vouliez vous
ne vouliez pas d'article ration pour la
majorité notamment les centristes en
voulez une vous êtes mis d'accord sur
pas d'automatique avec des critères de
Monsieur Marseille vous avez donc un un
article de compromis entre vous de
compromis entre vous que va va soutenir
le gouvernement et qui va corriger sans
doute à l'Assemblée nationale et on
verra en CMP on verra la fin qui vol le
texte ça c'est normal mais ne faites pas
croire non plus monsieur rotaillot que
l'article que vous avez déposé vous le
souhaitiez ardemment sinon on n'aurait
pas eu toute cette histoire donc la
vérité qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour
ceux qui nous écoutent il s'est passé de
la politique parlementaire il y avait
une majorité pour ne pas supprimer
l'article 3 et il n'y aurait une
majorité pour voter en revanche contre
le texte puisque les LR naurit
n'auraient pas été majoritaire comme
quand monsieur Marseille a déposé son
amendement pour pas supprimer l'article
3 et évidemment mes amis de la gauche
auraient été très content de faire
tomber le ministre de l'Intérieur en
votant contre le texte final tout en
votant l'article 3 alors j'ai un
instinct de survie assez développé
depuis quelques années et donc je veux
vous dire ici que la politique la
politique c'est assez simple ça se Batt
pour des convictions essayz d'avoir 100
% de ses convictions et quand on peut en
avoir 50 % et bien on peut être plus
heureux ça s'appelle un parti du
gouvernement ça s'appelle prendre ses
responsabilités merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est au président
buffet oui madame le Président
euh quelques précisions tout de même on
va sortir de
l'hypocrisie il y a une différence entre
l'article 3 du gouvernement au début du
texte et il y a une très grande
différence avec l'amendement à l'article
4 que nous avons déposé la différence
elle porte sur
quoi sur le caractère automatique du
titre de séjour accordé dans l'article 3
sur le fait qu'il suffisait simplement
de justifier que l'on veit un travail ou
d'expliquer que l'on avait un travail
sans vérification de la réalité de
celui-ci auprès de l'employeur et ce
dans un texte qui permettait de
régulariser largement et quasiment de
plein droit ça c'est l'article départ
donc il est clair que nous nétions pas
d'accord sur ce point la commission
n'était pas d'accord sur ce coin et le
fait que le texte l'article arrive en
séance je le dis à tout le monde mais
chacun le sait on l'a dit depuis le
début c'est parce qu'en
commission nous l'avons décidé que le
débate aurait lieu en séance que dit
l'amendement que nous avons déposé
conjointement avec nos collègues
centristes nos rapporteurs ont fait il
dit d'abord on ne passe pas par la loi
on généralise pas le dispositif on veut
du cas par cas le cas par cas c'est le
préfet
le préfet il est dans le cadre de
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
c'est le premier point d'entrée pour
quelqu'un qui aurait ser en situation
irrégulière et qui ser qui aurait un
contrat de travail qui aura qui un
contrat de travail donc qui viendrair le
préfet qui dans leadremission excep
séjour étudier la situation et le préet
vérifieraprès de l'employeur la réalité
de l'emploi ce qui permettra de vérifier
tout de même les employeurs voyou ce qui
n'était pas le cas de l'article 1 de la
du premier de la première mouture et je
pense que c'est quelque chose de très
important et de vertueux de ne pas
régulariser des gens qui sont
susceptibles de bosser pour des voyou
que les choses soient claires il y a
bien une
différence et j'insiste sur cette
différence elle me paraît absolument
essentielle alors oui c'est un compromis
bien évidemment que c'est un compromis
bien évidemment que nous l'avons discuté
avec nos amis centristes bien évidemment
que chacun a fait prévaloir son point de
vue et notamment sur les conditions bien
sûr et c'est bien normal et nous sommes
d'accord voilà donc on ne refuse pas de
régulariser des étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui ont un contrat de
travail on demande simplement par
principe que ce soit du cas par cas
c'est quand même une distinction
fondamentale avec learticle d'origine
donc que les choses soient claires que
la vérité soit dite que le débat est
lieu c'est très bien mais sur la base de
la vérité merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues la discussion est
ainsi les prises de parole sur AR qui
sont ainsi terminées je vais suspendre
dans quelques instants mais auparavant
je voudrais vous dire que l'ordre du
jour appelle la désignation des 37
membres du groupe de travail préfigurant
la commission spéciale chargé d'examiner
sous réserve de son dépôt le projet de
loi portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation au droit de l'Union
européenne en matière d'économie de
finances de transition écologique de
droit pénal de droit social et en
matière agricole en application de
l'article 8 bis alinéa 2 et 3 de notre
règlement les listes des candidats
présentés par les groupes ont été
publiées ces candidatures seront
ratifiées si la présidence ne reçoit pas
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévu par notre règlement il
appartiendra au Sénat de transformer ce
groupe de travail en commission spéciale
après le dépôt du projet de loi
conformément à l'article 16 bis de notre
règlement je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour la suite
de l'examen de ce texte et en
particulier les amendements sur cet
article 3 la séance est
suspendue